[Musique]
bonsoir est ravie de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro du 6 et 8 débat aille
speak english is presov ch par l'eau
italiano ablo espagnols près d'un
français sur deux ne se sentirait pas à
l'aise avec les langues étrangères
notre pays est d'ailleurs souvent
lanterne rouge dont plusieurs
classements des dispositifs existent
pourtant pour se perfectionner ses frais
en ile-de-france et dans les yvelines
alors les français nuls en langues est
ce une caricature ou bien une réalité
c'est le débat du jour et trois invités
pour en parler j'accueille anne
parillaud bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
régional vous êtes également vice
présidente de la commission emploi de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage au sein de la région et
vous avez notamment lancé il ya un mois
qui ose une plateforme gratuite
d'apprentissage des langues
on parlera bien sûr au contraire cette
émission à vos côtés claudine pierre
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
administrative du crl le terreau elle
celle au centre d'études et de
ressources en langues de l'ue vs qu il
ya trois distances et bien familial
trois sites dans les yvelines un ici à
saint quentin à versailles et un manque
la jolie est juste en face de vous une
attache à jour des monsois rarement
faire et vous êtes professeur d'allemand
en lice et vous est également docteur en
linguistique on parie qu il vous est
adhérente au snalc pour l'académie de
versailles c'est le syndicat national
des lycées et collèges
merci en tout cas à toutes les trois
d'avoir accepté l'invitation
alors je vous propose tout de suite en
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet avec ce
classement annuel du niveau d'anglais à
travers le monde pour l'année 2018 et
bien c'est en suède que le niveau de
compétence est le plus élevé suivie par
les pays-bas et singapour la france
comme vous pouvez le voir n'est que 35e
sur 81 88 88 pays qui sont pris en
compte dans ce classement est la france
donc avec un niveau de compétence
modérée en anglais et qui est également
queue de classement dans les pays de
l'union européenne alors est-ce que ce
classement vous surprend alors à titre
à titre personnel je ne suis pas du tout
surprise et je dirais qu'on est parti de
ce constat la région ile de france pour
travailler avec valérie pécresse et
vincent jean brun qui est le président
de la commission emploi formation
apprentissage justement pour travailler
sur ce projet de plate forme de langues
en e-learning tellement c'est un certain
manque et notamment par rapport au
marché de l'emploi
quel que soit son âge quel que soit son
milieu et et on est parti de ces
chiffres pour démarrer le projet alors
la présenterait évidemment en détail
tout à leur natasha jour 10 ce
classement est ce qui vous est ce qui
vous surprend
je ne parlerai pas d'une surprise en ce
sont des informations qui ont été
dévoilées à plusieurs reprises donc je
n'ai pas été étonné lorsque vous savez
dévoiler ce classement
en revanche moi je pense qu'il faut
toujours 2010 et s'est donné qu'ils sont
des données chiffrées
il y a aussi beaucoup d'autres
implications qui ne sont pas respectées
lorsqu on fait ce genre de sondage
en revanche là où nos points de vue
convergent
c'est l'idée de partir de ce constat
pour devrait être le sens d'un
perfectionnement linguistique et je
préciserai bien non seulement dans le
domaine des acquisitions de compétences
en anglais mais aussi dans l'optique de
plurilinguisme on parle justement
l'apprentissage des langues notamment
l'apprentissage de l'allemand dans les
lycées claudine pierse ce classement
avec la la france qui se retrouve
finalement en queue du classement niveau
européen en plus alors mauges une vision
bien sûr pas partielle de la chose
puisque nous dans notre dans nos centres
nous accueillons des étudiants mais
aussi les personnes en formation
continue formation tout au long de la
vie dont je vois un peu les deux aspects
parmi nos étudiants qui arrivent et qui
sont issus du baccalauréat
les niveaux sont très hétérogènes on
trouve des jeunes gens qui sont
quasiment bilingue mais aussi d'autres
nombreux qui sont quasiment débutants
donc c'est très hétérogène et parmi les
adultes en formation tout au long de la
vie eh bien on trouve de nombreuses
personnes qui sont obligées de se
perfectionner en anglais car maintenant
les de nombreuses poste exige dans les
entreprises goyer dans les entreprises
exigent des compétences en anglais quel
type de formation propose le ceren alors
le ceren propose des remises à niveau
qui sont fondés à la fois sur de
l'autoformation guidée des plates formes
à distance et du présentiel des ateliers
individuels où on peut cibler toutes les
lacunes des personnes ou tous leurs
besoins et des ateliers collectifs qui
permettent de prendre de l'aisance en
s'exprimant dans une langue étrangère
alors impérieux donc que vous en parliez
donc cette plateforme qui ose qui a été
lancé il ya à peu près un mois est
destiné aux franciliens de plus de 15
ans est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer un petit peu le principe de
cette plateforme
alors effectivement ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est une
plateforme extrêmement intuitive et
conviviale où on trouve
donc on s'est valu on arrive sur la
plateforme on s'inscrit sur la
plateforme c'est très simple je suis
moi-même inscrits d'ailleurs jeu
j'essaye d'améliorer mon niveau
d'anglais mon piètre niveau d'anglais et
on s'inscrit et ont fait une évaluation
de son niveau
donc on choisit sa langue évidemment
donc il ya quatre langues comme vous
l'avez dit donc anglais allemand
espagnol et français langue étrangère et
en fonction de son niveau donc on est
orientée sur tout un tas de produits
différents des séries tv des extraits de
films mais aussi des jeux de la
pédagogie des quizz de vocabulaire etc
donc c'est très très variés et donc à
partir de 15 ans on s'adresse aux
lycéens et on se situe aussi dans cette
formation tout au long de la vie où on
se rend compte que toujours pareil par
rapport à l'emploi
c'est un c'est un handicap majeur et
donc quelles que soient son âge on a
besoin voilà deux d'améliorer sa langue
et c'est gratuit
le service est gratuit le passé
aujourd'hui en tant que professeur vous
en pensez quoi de cette plateforme
c'est un dispositif ambitieux fuite il
jeu
je très peu de connaissances en ce qui
concerne le fonctionnement de ce
dispositif
je suis allé sur le site en prévision de
notre émission
donc moi je pense que ça pourrait être
aussi en équipe très motivant pour des
pratiques des différentes générations
que pourront leur permettre d'apprendre
une langue de façon soutenue et dans une
optique très très motivante
est ce que ça peut remplacer un
professeur sous types de plateformes
bien besoin justement pour j'ai donc
dans professeurs je pense que c'était en
complément d'apprentissage en complément
syrte très utile on très motivant mais
je pense que rien ne peut compenser des
interactions pour moi c'est ça la base
essentielle de notre travail en tant
qu'enseignant donc évidemment il ya
plusieurs optiques il est plusieurs
angles d'attaqué il ya plusieurs
possibilités de progresser en étrangères
ou et moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
véritable acquisition en des mains
étrangères sans contact ça pousse en
communication en laissant un territoire
interactions humaines perdriau ça fait
un mois donc ça et qui ose a été lancé
ce que vous avez déjà des chiffres
combien de deux personnes justement sont
inscrits sur le genre très rapidement
le site atteint 50 mille inscrits donc
on pense que dans les prochaines les
prochaines mesures c'est à dire on a été
lancé le 19 avril
fin juin il y aura à peu près cent mille
inscrits et s'est appelée évidemment
être totalement exponentielle c'est
vraiment un outil concret
pragmatique pour être complémentaire
évidemment de tout ce qui existe en
disait tout à l'heure avec ma voisine un
outil ludique vous l'avez dit que d'une
pierre justement est-ce qu'il faut être
ludique pour pour l'apprentissage des
langues
c'est une de nos philosophies aux
céréales on pense que justement le
l'école le lycée le collège sont là pour
apporter toute la rigueur de l'est de
l'éducation de la grammaire etc
après nous sert l on essaye de sortir un
peu de cette logique là est de plus
passé par la communication justement les
changes et par aussi des plateformes
telles que qui osent c'est très
intéressant parce que ça permet
justement de compléter comme disait
madame tout une formation il faut que
toutes les tous les moyens sont bons
pour apprendre une langue
il ne faut pas simplement se contenter
de faire des cures de temps en temps il
faut être actif dans son apprentissage
alors une étude récente également du
conseil national de l'évaluation du
système scolaire souligne que les élèves
français éprouvent des difficultés
d'expression orale en langue étrangère
est ce que vous vous le constatez entend
professeur est ce que les élèves ont du
mal à l'oral dans en allemand notamment
puisque vous êtes un menteur il ya en
certaines inhibitions qui mérite d'être
pour combattions d'indécence qu' on
essaie de faire en sorte que les élèves
soient mis en confiance et on essaie
aussi d'introduire des dispositifs qui
permettent d'accentuer cet axe de
communication aussi bien dans le cadre
scolaire que dans le cadre extrait
extrascolaires certes et lieu c'est ric
ur grammaticales qui vient d'être
évoquée par où
avec voir interdire excuses des excuses
et mangé mon père est explicité tout de
suite votre énorme des familles un monde
certes il ya les richesses lexicon mais
évidemment il ya aussi deux cadres
communicationnel donc la grammaire ce
n'est pas une fin en soi
on apprend de grammaire pour être
capable de transmettre un message et on
essaie de favoriser cet axe
communicationnel en cours mais aussi à
l'aide d'autres dispositifs notamment
voyages notamment échange donc récemment
nous avons organisé un échange grand
canyon 30 et longue tradition dans notre
lycée et c'est extrêmement motivant pour
les élèves
cela permet aux élèves qui ont un niveau
fragile des révéler leur potentiel en
glisse tic et certains parfois on place
le curseur très haut parfois il ya
certaines difficultés qui ne peuvent pas
être surmontés
mais l'idée c'est de n'est pas est très
exceptionnel hop excellent pendant les
dcd révéler son potentiel
vous parliez justement des séjours
linguistiques au niveau de la région est
ce qu'il existe des dispositifs d aide
pour les séjours linguistiques
c'est plus sur la notion de
par le biais de dellys et donc qui est
notre première compétence la deuxième
après les transports qui est une
compétence très importante dans lequel
on essaye d'introduire le maximum
d'expérience au niveau des langues de
création de lycées européens donc
d'action très concret dans le cadre des
budgets d'autonomie des lycées aussi
encourager toutes les initiatives des
proviseurs qui en matière de langue
également donc c'est c'est un tout après
la visée est aussi majoritairement
j'allais dire économique
parce que c'est aussi les langues c'est
l'accueil de 48 millions de touristes
aussi en région parisienne c'est aussi
la religion aussi voilà les vielles au
donc la volonté de la région et en
l'occurrence de valérie pécresse c'est
vraiment de créer la première région
multilingue c'est une vraie un vrai axe
politique est d'ailleurs la région a
investi 6 millions d'euros pour
développer cette plateforme et il y aura
progressivement de nouvelles
applications pour élargir un petit peu
la pratique des langues au niveau du
celi à des partenariats avec des lycéens
oui nous travaillons beaucoup avec les
lycées de la région notamment aussi avec
sur les cordées de la réussite nous
faisons à l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines la corde et
linguistique dont nous accueillerons six
emplois alors est ce un consiste à
proposer aux lycéens qu'il souhaite donc
c'est sur la base du volontariat et sous
certaines conditions je crois faut que
ce soit dans des zones en difficulté les
enfants en difficulté on leur propose
donc de venir en stage pendant les
vacances scolaires deux heures par jour
où ils vont travailler leurs compétences
en langues en autoformation d'une part
pour revoir les fondamentaux tous la
grammaire parce que c'est important
aussi et avec également des ateliers
d'expression orale qui sont animés par
nos étudiants vacataires dont qui sont
soit bilingue
parce que nous les testons soit ce sont
également des étudiants natifs donc ce
qui permet à nos lycéens aussi de
rencontrer d'autres cultures d'autres
des personnes de pays différents
on l'a on a parlé de l'étudiant parle
des lycéens on sait que l'apprentissage
des langues
il faut que ce soit fait dès le plus
jeune le plus jeune elle d'ailleurs
c'est assez récent en france
l'apprentissage notamment des langues
étrangères dès le primaire on voit
justement parlé mais juste après ce
micro-trottoir puisque océane bazire et
audrey chaillou ont demandé en aux
saint-quentinois justement ce qu'il
pensait plus généralement de
l'enseignement des langues
il faut que les profs de langues ce ne
se focalise pas justement sur les fautes
mais plus sur la facilité de la deûle
élèves à apprendre
on n'a pas assez d'heures d'anglais
au lycée on a juste quatre heures donc
même si c'est l'immersion totale que me
disent c'est pas c'est pas suffisant
pour apprendre une langue étrangère pour
nous à notre époque c'était moi c'était
moi pour nous c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
pas trop motivé là dessus mais qu'elle
n'a pas vu la chance non plus de pouvoir
sur nos études tout apprendre les
langues étrangères déjà mais maintenant
c'est vrai que pour les jeunes
maintenant c'est indispensable
je pense que ça vient pas forcément de
l'éducation nationale mais je pensais
que ça vient de la télé à savoir que en
france on a 100 % devait être ce qui
fait que ben on écoute de la vf on est
très contents dans le canapé on absorbe
ont fait rien on travaille pas de notre
cerveau natacha aujourd'hui je me tourne
vers vous vers la professeure j'ai donc
que pensez vous de ce que ce qu'on vient
d'entendre ce sont des avis intéressant
et judicieux je pense que xavi permet de
mieux comprendre plusieurs nuances qui
pourrait expliquer certains contre
performances dans le domaine
linguistique notamment en ce qui
concerne la maîtrise des langues
étrangères et même moi je considère
qu'il faut rester dans l'optique
positive il faut essayer de trouver des
leviers qui nous permettront d
mon de progresser de trouver des
optiques d'épanouissement linguistique
et que ce soit la motivation que ce soit
la lecture que ce soit contactez que ce
soit des voyages que ce soit perspective
de professionnels moi je pense que
plusieurs leviers évidemment et en
messieurs ce qui compte beaucoup c'était
la cohérence et la cohésion du parcours
linguistique
donc certes quand cette encre est dans
une optique devanture est évidemment les
programmes les progrès sont solides les
progrès peuvent être même remarquable et
ils vont s'y rend compte aussi que la
langue peut servir dans formidable trait
d'union entre les personnes mais aussi
entre les cultures mais une personne et
qu'il n'y avait pas assez d'heures de
l'anglais notamment
au lycée ou même au collège et est ce
que c'est vrai c'est un vaste débat donc
disons pour l'instant je préférerais me
concentrer sur les implications pour le
moment pédagogique ou des tactiques mais
évidemment les heures permettent tout
simplement de favoriser l'apprentissage
linguistique de nos élèves
ça me permet aussi de consacrer plus de
temps à ses lèvres
il est à moi il n'y a jamais trop de
retrait évidemment c'est aussi un
équilibre à trouver il ya des heures de
toutes les autres matières qui mérite
aussi d'être étudiée de façon très
soutenu une réaction par rapport à ce
micro trottoir
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé la première
intervention du jeune qui dit on n'ose
pas s'exprimer parce qu'en fait les
profs nous reprend nous reprennent
souvent sur les fautes etc
et je pense qu'en effet alors je suis
très très respectueuse la rigueur des
professeurs et je comprends tout à fait
néanmoins c'est vrai que pour la
pratique courante
on aurait envie moi ça me rappelle même
des souvenirs voyez on est marqué on
aurait envie de se lâcher plus
spontanément quitte à faire des fautes
parce que sinon on préfère rester au
fond de la classe et ne surtout rien
dire
voilà donc cette remarque qui m'amusait
une grille assez d'accord vous venez de
dire j'avais lu aussi dans dans un
article spécialisés que ce qui pouvait
le mieux apprendre les langues étaient
ceux qui osaient parler quoi qu'il
arrive
faute ou pas faute donc après ça dépend
que sa nature personnes
mais effectivement
le fait de pouvoir parler librement sans
se sentir oppressé par la correction
éventuelle du professeur ça peut libérer
l'apprentissage aussi finalement est ce
que tous ceux se joue dès le plus jeune
âge enfin je crois
est-ce qu'on a une chance quand même
d'apprendre même après passé un certain
âge parce que je me tourne vers vous
vers la tâche avec je l'espère moi je
pense que lorsqu'on commence
l'apprentissage mois à l'âge de trois
ans cinq ans quand on est en cours à
l'école maternelle
évidemment les perspectives sont très
très très ouverte et les progrès peuvent
être faits figurant en revanche je pense
que c'est ça la ferme et à traiter des
langues notamment des langues étrangères
c'est le fait que
c'est un domaine où verte de paris pour
faire à tout le monde
moi je pense qu'il n'est pas des ne
devrait pas s'imposer des limites qui
sont conditionnés par notre âge ou par
notre milieu social dans notre parcours
personnel
certes il ya des facteurs ou des
paramètres qui peuvent favoriser ou au
contraire entre l'apprentissage
linguistique plus complexe mais je pense
que c'est toujours possible
un père brio est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
suite a acquis aux peut-être plus de
plus de langues qui vont être la cible
sur la plateforme
alors il va y avoir des développements
de langue mais également de de
sectorisation c'est à dire qu'on va
développer par exemple le langage dans
la restauration dans les métiers en
tension plus particulièrement
ou parce qu'on n'aura pas la pratique de
l'anglais ou de l'allemand ou de
l'espagnol on n'aura pas le job
donc en fait sectorisé un peu
l'apprentissage par métier voilà donc
c'est les principaux développements qui
sont prévues au niveau du cls qui aussi
d'autres d'autres développements nous en
fait on est là pour accueillir bout bien
sûr les personnes qui souhaitent trouver
un job et qui en sont empêchés par ce
qui est leur manque les langues
étrangères
on peut les donc est préparé aussi aux
différentes espèce qu'on propose les
certifications qui permettent ensuite
aux personnes d'attester de leur niveau
comme le tohic où le taux fun ou le but
là dans l'émission touche bientôt à sa
fin mais on va commencer à conclure donc
sommes-nous vraiment mauvais en langues
étrangères est ce qu'il existe
finalement une recette miracle pour pour
apprendre une langue
je me tourne vers vous est ce qu'on peut
dire que les français sont vraiment si
mauvais que ça reprend étrangères
je ne pense pas en tout cas
l'expérience que je fait sur et teyran
avec mes élèves mais montrer qu'ils et
elles sont parfaitement capables de
progresser de façon parfois
spectaculaire en langue étrangère
lorsque ce sont ses sentent soutenus
lorsqu'ils se sentent respectés et
lorsqu'ils se rendent compte que les
dispositifs ont nos produits sont des
dispositifs qui leur permette de
déboucher au niveau d'un plastique mais
aussi au niveau culturel
je ne pense pas que que ce soit une fois
que la fatalité
je pense que kylie boost plusieurs
pauses et perspectives positives
claudine clair je suis d'accord je pense
qu'on peut apprendre les langues à tout
âge de plus maintenant je trouve qu'on a
de plus en plus d'outils comme cette
plateforme qui osent ou même maintenant
on peut regarder de nombreux films en vo
a soulevé justement dans le micro
exactement un peu regardé alerté en
allemand par exemple son replay et puis
même maintenant sur les replays france
télévisions il y a des replays en
version originale donc on a tous les
moyens maintenant pour pouvoir
s'améliorer en langue elle perdriau
alors c'est ce qu'on disait un petit peu
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de
concurrence c'est vraiment les langues
étrangères et leur apprentissage c'est
vraiment un domaine où tout le monde
peut s'exprimer peut avoir des
initiatives et c'est parce qu'on voit à
quel point on est complémentaires et il
y aura jamais assez de service pour
s'améliorer en langues
merci en tout cas toutes les trois
d'avoir été présent toi là c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat
[Musique]